To improve our child welfare system, we
have to improve the recruitment of the
people working in it.
Far too often, Child Protective Services
seems to attract applicants who don't
have other career options, who don't
quite understand what the job is, and who
don't have the skills to accomplish it.
Right now, child welfare workers are
overwhelmed. One report finds that the
estimated national average turnover rate
at child welfare agencies is
approximately 30%, with individual agency
rates as high as 65%. Some observers
focus on the possible solution of
offering higher compensation and lower
caseloads, but we should consider
recruiting applicants for CPS who are
interested in law enforcement,
not just social work, and we should
follow the lead of New York and Arizona
where the position is marketed as "first
responder". Going into homes where there
have been reports of abuse and neglect
can be dangerous, and figuring out what
has gone wrong requires serious critical
thinking and investigative skills.
Finding the right people for this job is crucial.
Do you think child protective
service workers should be considered
first responders? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.